you're watching the daily climate show
on
sky news on today's programme
we report from the villagers in germany
bulldozed to mine
coal despite the country's ambitious
environmental targets
calls for more to be done to help the
uk's puffins
under threat from climate change and
overfishing
and shooting not for the moon but for
the earth
more on the multi-million pound
environmental prize
launched by prince william
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and we meet those who are coming up with
the solutions
now germany has set itself ambitious
climate targets and is a leading voice
internationally
for the transition to greener energy the
country's chancellor angela merkel has
committed to phasing out the use of coal
by 2038 and becoming carbon neutral by
2045 that is rather than the more common
aim
of 2050. and after a recent court ruling
germany must now also reduce its
greenhouse gas emissions
by 65 by 2030.
yet there is a huge open-cast lignite
mine that is expanding in the west of
the country
and it's taking people's homes with it
whole villages are being demolished to
excavate
coal and service in part a neighboring
power station
the second most polluting in europe our
europe correspondent adam parsons has
traveled to the villages that are being
lost and met those who are fighting back
the roads and winding lanes are the only
remaining traces of a village now
wiped from the map this is imarat
there were hundreds of homes here just a
few years ago
plus a church a health center schools
all demolished to fuel germany's hunger
for
dirty brown coal all that's left now
are memories every day to the bus every
day from my house
to the bus stop
and now no bus no bus stop
nothing how do you feel sad
it's like mordor here petra grew up here
but there's no trace of her old home
this whole area is due to be engulfed by
a coal mine
owned by rwe the biggest energy company
in germany
the backbone of this nation's industrial
might
imarat was flattened to allow for the
expansion of this
massive open cast coal mine which
supplies a local power station
that is one of the most polluting in the
whole of europe
now the german government has got a plan
to phase out coal but at the same time
this coal mine has got plans to get even
bigger and that would mean the
demolition of more local villages
this is one of them lutzerrad most
residents have sold up and moved
but protesters have come in their place
determined to halt the destruction
and some of them living in trees as they
plan how to stop the looming demolition
we are rich in germany we have
a high income high living standards and
we need to
start making changes here because we can
so why do it rwe told us that abandoning
coal power
has to happen gradually it's got
something to do with the law
and this coal exit law says that um
guards viola mine is necessary
for the security of supply in germany
beyond 2030. nobody here
claims that coal is clean but they do
say it's vital
for the moment adam parsons sky news
western germany
while activists like those are hoping to
stop further expansion
of the godzvila coal mine in their
country one german environmentalist is
taking a more global approach
23 year old felix finkbiner founded
plant for the planet
to unite children and young people in a
mission to bring back
a trillion trees around the world here's
his story
i'm felix finkbeiner of plant for the
planet a children and youth organization
with the mission of
reforesting the planet to fight the
climate crisis
for us it all started about 14 years ago
when i was
nine years old and in fourth grade for
us children
forests are our future i was supposed to
give a little presentation in my class
about the climate crisis
and when i prepared that presentation i
found out about vangari mathai
[Music]
and that inspired us that we kids could
also be planting trees to fight the
climate crisis
so i told my classmates about it they
liked the idea and that's why a few
weeks later
we planted the first tree after one year
we had planted about 50
000 trees after three years the first
million and more and more children
started joining us all across the world
[Music]
on top of just calling on the world and
calling on others to restore forests we
of course want to plant as many trees as
possible
ourselves and this is why on the yucatan
peninsula in southern mexico
we have a wonderful team of just over
100 people doing their best
to restore and reforest um degraded and
destroyed forests
and we managed to plant up to two
million trees per year so far
and we hope to plant three million trees
this year alone
[Applause]
well in today's other climate news
police scotland
say the policing of protests at the cop
26 conference in glasgow will be
welcoming and friendly there are plans
to have 10
000 officers deployed each day during
the event that's due to take place in
november
it comes after the government announced
it will offer coronavirus vaccines to
cop
26 delegates who are otherwise unable to
access them
lloyd's of london the world's biggest
insurance market is
teaming up with prince charles to
support the environment
together they are leading the
sustainable markets initiative insurance
task force
it's made up of bosses from 17 of the
uk's largest
insurers it aims to support the
transition to a less
carbon-intensive economy part of our
challenge is to turn around and say how
do we partner with governments to say
actually there are insurance products
and there's a risk management service
proposition
that we could partner with the developed
economies to help support emerging
economies
through those disaster scenarios so
that's one of the ideas that we think we
can explore with government
smart way of putting money at the front
of a disaster rather than putting money
behind a disaster so let's be
preemptive and proactive rather than
reactive post loss
and scientists in greece are
investigating whether a layer of cease
not
in the aegean sea is connected to a
similar outbreak that's threatening
marine life in turkey the environment
ministry is using satellites to collect
data
after authorities on lemnos reported
seeing
mucus spots on parts of the island's
coastline
scientists are warning the so-called
c-snot is increasing
due to climate change and water
pollution
now there are calls for urgent action
for more to be done
to protect puffins the endangered birds
are native to the uk
but overfishing by scandinavian boats
off the coast of scotland
as well as the effects of climate change
are putting them at
even greater risk as skies james
matthews reports
[Music]
it's a hard life being a puffin and it's
getting harder
to look in their beak is to look at the
problem the sand eels the puffin fishes
to feed its young
are becoming smaller and harder to find
climate change is a factor
warming of the seas the plankton moving
north the sand deals following
and it's a real concern you know that
just slight increase in the in the sea
temperature
is having a big effect on the seabirds
which nests behind me here
overfishing of the sand deal in places
like this the isle of may
off scotland's east coast is also an
issue
combine that with climate change and for
the puffin
it's a perfect storm puffins need
enough food during the breeding season
to feed the chicks
that's the kind of cycle of life that
they need if they're not enough food at
the right time
then they're not able to successfully
breed and raise chicks and then
populations
populations go down so what we're seeing
is is
warming waters changing the composition
of the zooplankton
which is having a knock-on effect right
through the food chain into san diego so
there isn't the available sand deals at
the right time for puffins to feed their
chicks
there is a puffin chip it is a concern
for a sea bird
much loved and much hampered by changing
circumstances
the puffin is already deemed at risk of
global extinction
a popular symbol of nature's emergency
needing address james matthews sky news
on the isle of may
prince william has announced that london
will host the first awards ceremony
for his multi-million pound earthshot
prize
the nobel style environmental scheme
aims to discover and to scale
the best solutions to help repair our
planet
and tackle the climate crisis well we
can bring in eric levine now from
countess inn who are working with
earthshot prize and are encouraging
everyone
to take small steps to reduce their
carbon impact
eric good to talk to you a million
pounds is quite the incentive isn't it
you'd be tempted to have a go
do you think it will come up with
implementable solutions
i think it's yes and samantha wonderful
to be with you and and counter sin is
really proud partner of the earthshot
prize and and so looking forward to the
17th of october alexander palace
implementable i definitely think this
invitation
is going to bring forward some um some
breakthrough ideas and we need all of
them but the earthshot prize is
it's more than a prize it's always been
more than a prize it's about inviting
the best that our innovators
uh can bring to the table and things
that could really be game changing and
it's also about mobilizing
all of us uh to find the ear shots in
our own lives and and what can i do in
my
in my family this week that's an earth
shot in my own life or in my in my
workplace with my colleagues next week
uh and and all of us doing that together
yeah that's exactly the point isn't it
those encouraged to enter
not just big business or governments but
any individual
young or old and those solutions could
be big or small
yeah yeah that's absolutely right we
really do need uh
our our governments and our and our
cities to shift and to be
ambitious and we need bit we need
businesses to look at their own
transformation
engage their colleagues and engage their
customers but it's really a question
this this decisive decade
2020 to 2030 where the prize is
is is giving out um you know these these
five
opportunities for a breakthrough in a
spotlight but it's really a clarion call
for all of us
um to rally behind and that's why doing
it together
uh it is it is possible if we act
quickly and if we act
ambitiously doing any of it alone um
uh won't cut the mustard no one prize no
one business no one government
can provide the solution but all of us
together can add up to something bigger
and that's why the prize and count us in
have invited people to do that and be
counted together and then the platform
that we have where you can go and take
practical steps
in your own life use your voice reduce
your carbon footprint
and it can and you can see the impact of
that and have it all add up together
well we look forward to hearing about
those prize-winning submissions eric
levine thank you for talking to us
wonderful to be with you well that's
everything from us for this week but
don't forget to check out our digital
show
over the weekend in the latest episode
we go behind the scenes of inzamam
rashid's investigation
into the uk's acid tar lagoons that's
available
for you on sky news social channels our
app
and website and on climatecast
this week we dig deeper into the causes
and effects of
air pollution and look at how it can
amplify
not only the impact of covid but social
injustice as well
that is available wherever you normally
get your podcast from
anna jones will be back next week at our
normal time
here on sky news thanks for watching